my name is Ella and I love pranks I one
time pranked my boss at work by putting
baby goats in his office let me tell you
the story of the time I pranked my
family with an emu egg so my friend at
work Sarah Ruben ordered a bunch of a
man bag I think she was filming a video
where she had people make omelettes out
of emu eggs she asks me if I want to
keep one and I say yeah definitely like
I'm gonna figure out what to do with it
I have this emu egg my parents have a
chicken coop I'm gonna put this anyway
in the coop where the chickens lay that
hits I'm gonna see what their reaction
is this footage was actually captured
two years ago but I hadn't done anything
with it yet and I decided now is the
time so they have this coop they have
these two chickens the chickens are cute
I don't live there but I thought how
funny would it be if I put this egg
inside of their coop and made it seem
like the chickens laid the egg haha
flip-flops so my mom is really sellable
and my dad is just a Brazilian aloof
kind of guy like it's pretty easy to
trick them oh my god we were filming
secretly I had the camera in my pocket
what is that logic because they don't
work
[Laughter]
what happened is that my mom is a
religious mexican-american woman and she
was not having it she was like this is
some devilish like it's like what what
happened that's not really oh my god
it's like like a super chicken if those
little chickens can play these eight we
are rich there's something side this
might be out of space the meteor is
scary no don't touch it shaken he's like
you think we're gonna make money off
these chickens if they like eggs like
this we can have a thousand chickens
they're worth oh come on you have to do
it apart I don't know I don't want to be
secured what if it's a bad thing I want
to see what's inside can you describe it
talking it doesn't crack are you honest
it needs you to do you gotta just get
dirty
[Music]
kind of animal does that that yolk came
out and she was freaked out she was mad
at me I'm not gonna lie like she's the
reason why I haven't made this video yet
is because she told me not to but here
we are
are you mad that I prank you know it was
a lot of fun and very smart yeah mom was
the one who really got it what did you
think it was one I thought it was
something not good like good inside the
chick me did you think you 4head done
did you think that chickens laid it no I
was pretty sure that you could sound
later but I thought it might be some
animal living in the coop to deal with
some scary animals very action was so
hilarious and there is really no harm
done like what else was I going to do
with this EMU egg
I had to print them what do you think my
chickens thought one day for chicken do
I have to look to a psychologist not
friend for like a session I don't like
okay well I do anyway thank you so much
for watching email um like it like the
video don't don't share it though so I
don't want my mom to see this
[Music]